o la de momento de conocer cuáles son
las principales noticias en materia
económica que afecta en américa latina'
y al resto del mundo y lo haremos con
nuestro compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bueno comenzamos en argentina sigue
padeciendo la inflación y en enero
aumentó aún más así que sí bueno ya se
puede considerar que argentina tiene una
de las inflaciones más altas del mundo
en dinero la inflación interanual fue
del 50,7 por ciento mientras la
inflación en comparación con el mes
anterior fue del 3,9 por ciento lo que
evidencia los problemas del país para
enfrentar sus desequilibrios económicos
el instituto nacional de estadísticas y
censos confirmó que este aumento de
enero se vio impactado por aumentos en
los servicios de salud telefonía e
internet y los relacionados al turismo
hace como un aumento en los precios de
los alimentos para varios economistas la
inflación alcanzará este año el 55 por
ciento superior al 59% registrado en
2021 esto pese al compromiso asumido por
el gobierno argentino ante el fondo
monetario internacional de recortar la
emisión monetaria para financiar el
tesoro
pero también dicen que esta acelerada
inflación tiene sus raíces en la
flexibilización del control de precios
que había impuesto el gobierno de
argentina y que al corto plazo habrá más
reducciones de subsidios como por
ejemplo el transporte para cumplir con
los compromisos que adquirieron con el
organismo financiero jorge de argentina
vamos a colombia donde el dato
macroeconómico parece bastante distinto
de verdad así que en colombia el
crecimiento del producto interno bruto
en 2021 fue del 10,6 por ciento con
respecto al 2020 según las autoridades
del instituto nacional de estadísticas
de colombia este crecimiento fue
impulsado por sectores como el comercio
alojamiento alimentos y transporte así
como en la industria manufacturera es
necesario recordar sí que este repunte
es parte del conocido efecto rebote post
pandemia que en 2020 esa economía cayó 7
por ciento actividades artísticas de
entretenimiento y otras de servicios
crecieron el 33 por ciento pero las
buenas noticias pueden ser opacadas por
datos negativos como el de la inflación
y también el del desempleo
y las bebidas no alcohólicas mostraron
un incremento del 20% en el último año
los colombianos ahora pagan 140 por
ciento más que hace un año por una papa
por ejemplo y hasta un 34% más por la
carne de res porque viajamos ahora hasta
túnez que está aprobado a recibir un
préstamo por parte del banco mundial así
es y bueno el gobierno dijo que este
dinero servirá para financiar las
reformas sociales y las pequeñas y
medianas empresas el banco mundial
autorizó desbloquear el primer tramo de
un préstamo de 350 millones de euros a
túnez asimismo el banco mundial otorgará
un segundo préstamo del que no
precisaron el monto para apoyar al país
en su lucha contra el coronavirus ayer
informadas informamos sobre el inicio de
las negociaciones con el fondo monetario
internacional para un nuevo crédito que
le va a permitir ejecutar el presupuesto
general del estado aunque este
presupuesto santiago ya tenga un déficit
público de 2600 millones de euros el
equivalente al 6% de su producto interno
bruto
hasta bahrein para hablar de un hecho
considerado por muchos como históricos
no me refiero a la primera visita
oficial de un jefe de gobierno de israel
así la visita se da luego el
restablecimiento de las relaciones
diplomáticas en 2020 en el marco de los
acuerdos de abraham esto que fueron
impulsados por eeuu el primer ministro
israelí naftalí bennett dijo que era un
enorme honor reunirse con el rey de
bryant y al concluir una visita que da
un mensaje poderoso contra su
archienemigo común iran el rey hamad bin
isa al-khalifa dijo que la visita de
benet un día histórico bennett se reunió
con varios ministros del gobierno y
abordó la necesidad de una mayor
cooperación en materia económica y
militar a principios de este mes el
titular israelí de defensa de nigrán
visitó esta monarquía del golfo antes lo
hizo también el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de israel seguir lápiz quien
viajó para inaugurar la embajada de
israel a lo mejor ahora de los
indicadores de la jornada que nos dicen
hoy bueno todos los indicadores fueron
influenciados por el conflicto de rusia
y ucrania wall street cerró con ganancia
por esta visión de una desescalada en
ucrania después de que rusia anunciara
el repliegue de sus tropas en europa el
principal índice de la bolsa de parís el
cac-40 cerró con una subida del 1 86 por
ciento y en américa latina la bolsa de
sao paulo volvía a subir y avanzó un
0.82 por ciento para cerrar la cifra del
día cuál es hoy la cifra del día es
112.3 millones de personas eso vieron el
superbowl en 2022 16 por ciento más que
en 2021 y es el superbowl más visto en 5
años jorge muchísimas gracias por este
recorrido por las principales noticias
en materia económica nuestra audiencia
le invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]